[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode a
Kos and I'm here today to bring you the
greatest and probably my most prized
possession this is what has ignited all
of my collection my statue collection
and has pushed me to the forefront of my
John rod to be honest with you and it's
balls down to your passion whose your
passion for oh just seeing the Hat right
IOP I in Lord podcast Sunday is at 11:00
during football season and 1:00 p.m.
standard Eastern Time when football
season is in the bushes
shout out to in the bushes that shirt is
in the teespring store as we speak Oh
Lords of gaming dotnet that's the
website you know what it is we moving
out here hey back to this wonderful
statue now a lot of you guys don't
understand different stages of the Hulk
the reason why I chose to use this
statue first this society shows Premium
Format gladiator Hulk the reason why I
decided to use this statue first was
because like I said before it started
off everything I was walking past
Forbidden Planet and I saw him in window
when I saw him in a window I said oh my
god Randy there I actually got a price
and
he said enough scene number and I just
looked at I'm like okay I looked at the
name who made it and I went online and
found out dudu cost that price I needed
to have them the level of detail is
insane so it's based on one of my
favorite comic book lines of the
incredible the most well known storyline
of The Incredible Hulk and probably the
most botched story line when they
regurgitate it of the Incredible Hulk
and and I'm gonna give you the reasons
why Marvel botched it why Disney botched
it and why Marvel comic books was the
true source and four reasons why they
couldn't get it right but let's get back
to sideshow statute first um I needed to
have it and I went in there I made an
impulse decision I went to the bank took
out money had money in my pocket to add
to it and boom let's make it happen
bought it in the house and it's like wow
where did this guy go so one first and
foremost had to upgrade my living
situation second he went through a lot
of bumps and bruises when you first get
your statues your first statue is gonna
go through a little Nick's and cuts a
little bumps and bruises and along the
way he's gonna stay with you I mean he's
no he's no exception to the rule he had
breakage he's lost a piece of his
feather on his head his horn his eye out
his head but he looks as just as good as
any sets where I get brand-new out the
box with no flaws the reason why is
because it's going to be a nut not
another like this statute this statue is
mainly my reason for collecting so let's
give you the story and give you the
differences Marvel has three stories of
them telling about Planet Hulk Planet
Hulk is the storyline in which gladiator
Hulk has come from so letting you know
Hulk has come from this storyline right
you say okay what makes up gladiator huh
well what a group of superheroes decided
to do was check the hall to go into
space and once he was on the Tony Hawk
mainly once he was on the space shuttle
to go out into space is only he was able
to do it because only he was able to get
through the van handling belt
and only him he was able to tackle the
problem at hand that's what they
explained to him because he was
so-called a menace on earth he goes out
there they cheap tricked them jettison
him to another planet something happened
when him when he was raging inside the
ship he knocked the navigation control
off center and he fell on a planet so
when he got to the planet he was taken
into custody if you see on his chest he
has a submission disk on his chest right
and that allowed the Red King to control
him because you have to understand the
Incredible Hulk is a force of nature
with that stunt that's on his chest
it weakened him when he landed on the
planet who was getting acclimated to
everything around him and surroundings
the world's gravity everything of that
nature so while his body was building a
tolerance for it he was at a weakened
state and writing stories you have to
make sure that you foster the stories in
order for the stories to get to where
you want them to be now the path set out
we're not gonna get into the further
books we're just gonna talk about
gladiator Hall because I do have further
stuff that you know came along and then
you gonna understand exactly where I'm
going with this right so on this planet
he was forced to fight in the great
games now and the movies Thor Ragnarok
which told you of a version of this
story but did not tell it to you
properly
I understand they didn't have certain
characters and I had to get Hawke off
planet before the movies they got Hulk
or planet and he told why
in thor ragnarok so and throw a Ragnarok
they showed you him fighting Thor and a
great arena and that's how they broke
out of there and the Grandmaster was the
one that was holding him down no that's
not how it really went inside the books
the planet was closed a car and on that
planet hulk fell in love with a woman
they fostered a child she was pregnant a
bomb blew up what was on the ship
because I had a nuclear reactor it
killed her he raged and left off the
planet that started World War Hulk and
that's when he got retro retribution on
the Illuminati the people that send them
there those people which comprised of
Professor Xavier mr. fantastic Black
Bolt Iron Man and Doctor Strange okay so
now that those that that's that part of
the story is out already throw a rock
and rock debacle then you had the Planet
Hulk on cartoon that was done now in
that he fought better rebuilt the only
reason why he fought better rebuilding
that because they needed to get a
character that they actually armed to
show who he was fighting opposed to who
he originally fought in the comic books
right so it wasn't thought so they used
better rebuild so that's why the the
universe and the MCU they used or
because and what is it the MC comic book
world I don't know they use better a
bill to further along a story in the
actual book they use the Silver Surfer
which was called the the silver savage
and they fought there then that was to
show you how strong those stunts this
was because this Silver Surfer has
cosmic powers now I actually have a door
rum of that battle of gladiator Hulk vs
silver savage and I will be showing that
probably next time or probably
thereafter because that was a sword
after sideshow piece that I want it was
a door um of those
two combatants actually fighting from
the book and I thought it depicted them
perfectly so we're gonna go over the
details of the statue not I gave you the
backlog right so the one true story is
Planet Hulk and if you would want to
have a great read I suggest you go get
that book when he got to earth it was
called world war hulk because he the
leashed war upon the earth and
retribution and revenge for his fallen
wife and his child right which we will
get to that in another date because I
have a statue that depicts that child
and you will love that statute of
sections fantastic
so this statue depicts gladiator Hall
probably before fight or after conquest
he has a sword which you can see has
many Nicks and cuts on it that he used
in battle it's mixed-media the skirt
that he has on it it is made out of
leather and it's another material under
that which is very nice the stunt disc
actually comes off that's on its chest
the shield is a second piece within
itself is made out of many different
tones it looks like brass mixed with
copper mixed with gold and a silver ish
finish to give it off a real rustic look
his shoulder has the spikes the base is
on outstanding base wears a lot of
intricate parts and moving parts to it
when you put it together also you see
broken swords on the base so the base is
like a step up it has a museum type fish
pose and the character is depicted in a
very strong manner if you look at the
fingernails the fingernails are
incredibly done everything on the Statue
screamed I needed to have it and scream
The Incredible Hulk at its finest one of
his one of my favorite books when it
comes to the character and I'm sure that
you will love the book if you ever get a
chance to read the book also just watch
the movie and if you ever seen Thor
Ragnarok you can actually look at that I
have
Dora Rama then I picked up looking at
past king of the statues where I have
gladiator Hulk vs. Thor
you'll love it it looks very nice so
this is the part in the video well I'm
going to ask you to like follow and
subscribe and if you like anything that
I said right now make sure you put those
notifications and buttons on so you can
get all the scale West goodness also go
to Lords of gaming dotnet where ILP iron
Lords podcast is and you can see Lord
kognito you can see myself attic and
Lord sovereign as we have different
guests on the show and we can talk about
different range of topics from sports to
mainly video games and also what's going
on in industry as a whole trade shows
the stuff that's happening that you
should be concerned with when it comes
to video games and such also go to Lords
of gaming got net where what I just told
you is also there
hey guys I have fun what you can't wait
to see you again next week when I'm
bringing you another Incredible Hulk
statute I don't know which one is gonna
be this time because my collection is
mainly incredible hulks I've known I
know that we went through probably what
4050 statues right now and I probably
gave you one or two incredible hulks now
I got you don't worry I got a whole lot
more and I can't wait to show you my
collection remember at the end of the
year I probably do a room review so you
can see some statues inside the room or
maybe not maybe I won't do a room review
because there's still statues to show
you guys see you next week
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]